Hi! I'm asking you to raise your arms and wave back, just the way I am, kind of a royal wave.
You can mimic what you can see.
You can program the hundreds of muscles in your arm.
Soon, you'll be able to look inside your brain...
... and program, control the hundreds of brain areas that you see there.
I'm gonna tell you about that technology.
People have wanted to look inside the human mind, the human brain, for thousands of years.
Well, coming out of the research labs just now, for our generation, is the possibility to do that.
People envision this as being very difficult.
You had to take a spaceship, shrink it down, inject it into the bloodstream.
It was terribly dangerous.
You could be attacked by white blood cells in the arteries.
But now, we have a real technology to do this.
We're gonna fly into my colleague Peter's brain.
We're gonna do it non-invasively using MRI.
We don't have to inject anything. We don't need radiation.
We will be able to fly into the anatomy of Peter's brain,...
...literally fly into his body, but more importantly, we can look into his mind.
When Peter moves his arm, that yellow spot you see there...
...is the interface to the functioning of Peter's mind taking place.
Now you've seen before that with electrodes, you can control robotic arms,...
...that brain imaging and scanners can show you the insides of brains.
What's new is that process has typically taken days or months of analysis.
We've collapsed that through technology to milliseconds, and that allows us...
...to let Peter to look at his brain in real time as he's inside the scanner.
He can look at these 65,000 points of activation per second.
If he can see this pattern in his own brain, he can learn how to control it.